presumably you liked spending time with
them because you famously you have a lot
of livestock don't you
yes i have goats and sheep and and
cattle
and a lot of chickens you know these
terrible battery farms which i
thoroughly disapprove of one was going
bust the other day
and there were a lot of chickens looking
for homes i already have about 24
chickens
so now i'm up to 36 i think at last
count
it's at least 36. so there's a gang of
them out there
and they all think i'm wonderful so it's
it's
it's like having it's like having tom
jones fans actually
i'm very good
bitty piper you too have joined the
world of chicken owners
yeah we have we have chickens we have
two chickens
just the two just the two um what are
they called
one's changed its name a few times
bright bomber and then it was bob
and and then the notorious chicken
um cockrell both cockrells wanted layers
got cockrells it's like potluck
um his name is heavy metal wait a minute
those
so these are the two cockrells this is
one cockerel
in different poses okay and this is a
competitive bird
you can enter them for competitions they
have amazing clues
that's what happens but it's actually
i think that's a competition anyone
wants to do
but it's it looks fantastic
it does but it's awful it's a horrible
aggressive um cockerel um it's become a
he's become a real problem and loud very
loud but sort of swoops down at you
chases you around the garden puts his
wing out
and sort of circles you um and now is
doing this
um so and apparently i said i said to
this guy down the road like what am i
going to
do about this and he's like you just got
to show him who's boss
but he's so gorgeous how could you
possibly discipline
i think he's very frustrated because i
think he wanted this competition life
i mean he said he got asked in lockdown
what he might like is a hen
i mean i'm not a vet but uh that might
cheer him up
i can't risk taking any more risk
and samuel you've talked about your
animals on the show before and i
hesitate to ask
am i still alive sam
you're not in here live you're the
number one bull now
[Laughter]
now it's less good news i believe for
james nesbitt
uh well jimmy ness but jimmy served us
well
but uh he got old and very arthritic
oh yeah is he not married is he no
longer with us
he's no longer with us he had to be put
down he was in he was in quite a lot of
pain
and he gave him an honorable um
uh burial down at the end of the farm um
a huge grave i mean this size per house
it'll take one for me wait a minute you
dug a hole for that
yeah yeah absolutely
don't don't don't while well our animal
expert andy has a question
does livestock explode after it's
expired
is that urban myth a rural it's a very
urban myth
i made it jimmy and his prime jimmy
nesbitt in his prime was something to
behold though
sam is that all right yeah it's a
fantastic fantastic ball
um the distinguished name like um jimmy
jimmy i couldn't really turn him into
sausages so he's here's a grave
and a little marker on him so
have you got a tom jones yet surely tom
jones is
is ripe for the farm and i'm welcome
oh my god i've got a couple of new rams
who are who are
unnamed well hello